好 今天來講一下支撐跟壓力點位正確的使用方式
這也是市場上非常非常多人都會共同犯的錯誤
就是我們可能會拿到一些
關於商品的支撐跟壓力的點位嘛
然後例如說現在的價格在這邊
那有人拿到支撐壓力他就會直接掛
OK那我就掛17400麥
17300麥
那其實這個動作是錯的
因為你正確應該要做的是
如果
他漲超過17400麥例如說漲到17410
然後又再跌破400麥的時候
這時候你試駕進場空單
而且是試駕空
這個才是正確的方式
因為
這邊
轉折往下的時候
你是在
趨勢往下的時候打空單
而不是在
被灌破往上的這個點
打空單
呃
甚至你還不是打空單
你是被戳過穿過去
那
這個
這個是完全不一樣
你都是一樣
17400麥空
但是你打的是一個是正確的單
一個是錯誤的單
如果你是在這個地方掛著
被灌過去
那你是在上漲的過程中打的空單
但是這個
往下的時候
在這個地方打的空單是
你在趨勢開始轉折之後打的空單
所以
這樣是對的
這樣是錯的
那
另外一個點
這個
是
如果啊
你是掛17300的多單
就掛在這邊
然後
70價格在這邊
那
我們是不是
常常會看到一根
例如說
500口
甚至1000多口的
他就直接這樣子灌下來
那
說不定他就直接灌到了
例如說
那如果你是一個
你是一個會停損的人
然後他就直接打到你的停損點了
那
你是不是就進場一秒就停損了
你的
掛在這邊的多單
1730多單
一秒之後就到17280
那你就一秒停損
那這個單有什麼意義呢
所以是不是你應該是要等到
他在往上轉折之後
在這個地方進場
這樣才不會
發生這種
一秒停損的情況
而且這種很長的一根
就是暴漲或暴跌
其實是非常常見的
那這個還是會停損的人
還有一種
更糟糕的
就是
不停損的人
例如說
他就
打到
就是一根直接從
這個
噴了30點下來
變17280
但是他還是
不停損的
因為他覺得
哇
進場一秒我就要停損了
那我超不想停損
就直接不停損
然後就一路往下
又打到17200
那
那這個不就是吃了一段超級無敵大的
就可能他本來是會停損的人
但他不想一秒停損
結果他就變成一個不停損的人
然後
這個蒙受一個超巨大的虧損
那另外一個
這個的好處是
你看
如果在這邊
轉折了
那他是不是就變成是在支撐2進場
那他的成本就是17200
那他就不會先進到17300的單
就是
這個支撐就被灌破了
那他就沒有在那個地方進場
好
所以這個
這個
今天要講的
第一個點是
這個被測試過的支撐才是支撐
被測試過的壓力才是壓力
那
如果支撐就被灌破了支撐就會變成壓力的位置
就是支撐跟壓力點位
說的是那個地方很可能有重兵防守
多方跟空方
分別可能會在那個地方
就是想要守住那個價錢
那個地方很有可能有多空交戰
那一個地方
可能
會有多空交戰
會有重兵防守
並沒有說他會守住啊
有人防守沒說他會守住啊
你要知道他守住了
那這樣好像多方
可能
要開始一段優勢
那你才在
這個守住之後
打多單
好
所以
這個總結一下
第一個是
這個
要在
趨勢開始轉折之後
進場
你的單
就不要摸頭猜底
然後
這個我今天最主要要講的是
就是不要直接在壓力的點位掛空單
然後在支撐的點位掛多單
這個方法
這個方式是錯的
這樣的話
你就會
一進場
就是逆勢單
而且
很可能一開始成本就非常非常的差
好
這個是一個
非常非常多人犯的錯誤
跟大家提醒一下
不是,不是,不是